you
if it was up to you would you make child
support illegal or do you think it has
its place um i would just go around and
just say as in for both parties like
just as a institution yeah as an
institution should be able to blame
child yeah yes yes it depends it depends
so in some situations yeah some
situations yes so is it legal or illegal
i don't know well child support's legal
now um and i'm asking do you think it
should be yeah it should be legal um
it depends on it so i'm gonna wait in
here in it okay
yes but it needs to be the way it needs
to be calculated it needs to be fair
like if she can't she's not if she's
earning a lot of money then
there needs to be some adjustment for
that okay
i say
yes but
it's controversial you know i was just
thinking though because if they've got
equal custody of the child then no
because when the use with me i'll pay
when it's with you you'll pay and that's
it in it that would just make sense
but if i'm paying you money and then i'm
taking my child and spending more money
when i have my child then to me it don't
really make sense in it like i come from
a home where my dad paid for everything
like even my mom and dad weren't
together and they didn't live in the
same house my dad always bought my
school uniform bought my shoes he bought
everything so
really and truly if he never paid child
support or whatever you wouldn't need to
because he bought everything what about
there's a large disparity of income
where
one parent affording a child a lifestyle
of a private school certain luxuries and
then the other parent can't keep up with
that and then you find that
that pair that kid is now
feeling just hiding away i think that
dad would still be paying for the
private school though no no no sorry i'm
saying when he's with the dad that the
lifestyle they're living is different so
when he's with him why does he have to
fund her lifestyle yeah
because
the separation the it's the challenges
to figure out how to work it out
yeah
yeah you could see as opportunity rich
dad poor dad in real life
i don't see the need for child support
to be honest in like most cases go on
elaborate yeah because i don't
understand you can't get a job the [ __ ]
why do you need his money 100 like what
what what on earth why are you entitled
to a man's money i think in the modern
day if you're especially if you chose to
leave with like most of the time women
leave why do you deserve this money
you're gonna you're gonna you're gonna
leave and then rob man yeah it's true if
you knew you couldn't get my money would
you have left
that's what you have to ask them would
you would have stayed that's why i might
say it's cheaper to keep her in there
but it goes back to it goes back to no
consequence so i can marry a man and
leave him so make a poor decision for
the family and take half his [ __ ] what
the [ __ ]
i guess we're thinking selflessly here
because um
we should we should be thinking about
the child's interest in mm-hmm not the
actual not because if we if we're like
okay you need to get a job don't get his
money but the child isn't affected in
that so it's not the it's not the woman
maybe she should think about that before
she leaves him
i'm not i'm not favoring any one of them
yeah i'm just talking about the child
because he the child is affected yeah so
so so to me if you took away child
support it would take away the incentive
for women to leave because now they're
rewarded for leaving mm-hmm so the
incentive to have kids but but that
depends on each case though because some
cases the the guy leaves
twenty percent
i wouldn't say i'm i wouldn't go through
proportions i could i wouldn't go
through data i'm just talking about
different societies right and but what
i'm saying is that i don't think he
should just leave for no reason too i
think people are really not careful
nowadays when it comes to having
children how do you know how do you know
that you know the money is solely being
used for the child
you don't and that's a lot of the reason
why a lot of men don't want to pay the
money bro because they're like hold on
like i'm gonna pay in nine grand a month
child support it's like yo what kind of
food you eating in there especially when
she has another man in the house but
you're still paying but that's that's
not about that
but that's your child at the end of the
day like
if she is earning more than him i
wouldn't say that the guy should give uh
child support i would say she should be
doing that she should be taking care of
them i'm not talking i'm not favoring
any of any one of them and i know it's
wrong to ask men for child support if
she has if she left or if she has done
it by herself
and vice versa if she left if he left
she shouldn't be like taking full
responsibility of the child because it
was his mistake too you know it's just
like a matter of accountability as you
said it's it's that don't you think it's
accountability for choosing the right
partner exactly oh definitely right so
so what i'm saying is if you take away
child supports peop child support people
have to face the consequences for their
actions immediately so if you're going
to pick a reckless husband that's going
to leave you for a younger model in 10
years you'll face the consequence 100 if
you're gonna leave him and take half
like you can't take half anymore so if
you want to leave you have to really
think about it and to me to me this
would put the child's best interests at
heart because there are more
consequences for leaving and and a child
is at risk if there's one parent in the
home that's why i'm saying that we're
thinking selflessly here set like
selfishly here because we don't think
about the child we're thinking about
individual interests well i'm thinking
about the child because it like from in
my point of view if you take away child
support more families would stay
together because there's less of an
incentive to leave and you're going to
have less women trying to catch a check
by getting a baby off of the man i
believe if a person is selfish it's
regardless though even if it's a man or
a woman
when you say women do you think women
would steal condoms from drake
no i'm serious like because remember
when we see celebrities that's the
extreme but that means in society women
are doing this just at a smaller rate so
there are girls trying to catch kids
from rich guys all the time
because they know about child support
yeah i know i know that of course there
are people who would use that for their
own advantage i'm just saying here if if
we actually think about child's interest
then there should be child support
because they're the only ones affected
here so how how does that benefit the
child when you don't know if the mother
is going to spend it on the child yeah
of course that's what i'm saying it's
not it's it's still selfish because if
she is asking for child support and
we're not even seeing what the financial
status it's selfish itself it's it's
unfair on the guy because we're asking
for something extra from him right but
it should it should be equal it somehow
because if she is earning more than him
she should be taking care of the child
and vice versa so if it's 50 50 custody
why is she entitled to his money if he
makes more yeah fair enough yeah
no nobody is going to say that this is
what's going to happen it should have
measures in place so that we know the
money's being spent on the child yeah
yeah exactly there should be so it's not
it's the fault is not on the
consequences the fault is maybe we need
to keep a check on that it is because if
there were consequences to it you
wouldn't do it so if i thought but we
know we know the consequences we
couldn't couldn't the man just spend the
money on the child and not get the
process involved like why does he need
the children a lot of men wouldn't do
that because
i can only talk from my community a lot
of men won't do that yeah i'm talking
i'm talking about my dad did my dad paid
for everything blood but i'm sure
growing up in the block you know a bag
of man that don't know their dad yeah
that's different but that's different
but that's different if you don't know
your dad in it but i'm saying yeah like
there's men that are involved
want to see their kids ain't allowed to
see that this it depends
women are taking money from them and
telling them they can't see their kids
what behavior does this incentivize this
incentivizes women to pick bad men and
know that even even if they're shitty
dads they can still get bailed out um
yeah it's because it goes back on
accountability exactly yeah but that's
what i'm saying i'm saying child support
takes away accountability from women
because even in this example right where
he has to spend it on the kid that's
saying to the woman you can pick a
shitty partner and you still get bailed
out
there's a trade there's a trader for
every concert